but during cloak and daggers when you
came up with the idea for fright night
right what happened was they came to me
and they said uh we want to do we want
to do we want to do a remake of the
window
the window was the juvenile version by
Cornell Woolrich of rear window and
Cornell Woolrich wrote both books and it
is the quintessential boy who cried
Wolf's story and I said you can't do
this this is this is just I've seen this
too many times it's too thin
you know and that's when I came up with
the imaginary character Jack fly I wrote
an original basically Cloak and Dagger
is an original
and uh
but I said if you really want to do a
kid looking out the window and seeing a
murder in the house next door and you
want to make it fresh and you want to
make it appealing to your younger
demographic
have a kid love a harm yet of a Mad
horror fan look out his window and see a
vampire chomping down in the house next
door and everybody thought I was nuts I
mean they all thought I was crazy it's a
cool idea I went and took a meeting at
Universal Tom Mount I think and I
couldn't convince him everybody thought
I was crazy now you got to remember that
moment in time
vampires were excuse the expression dead
dead dead
the the vampire the the vamp the the
most recent vampire movie was love at
first bite with George Hamilton right
which is farce right when they start
doing farce it lets you know that the
genre is dead it's exhausted it has to
be reinvented right it needs a breather
uh uh you've you see that with yeah sure
you don't see it all the time see it all
the time and so
I
I you didn't give up no I couldn't get
the idea out of my head because it was
so delicious yeah and and really so I
sat down I couldn't think out of I kept
saying well what would what would
Charlie Brewster do if he if he had a
vampire next door well who would he go
to for help nobody's ever going to
believe him and then I thought of all
those horror hosts that I had grown up
with oh yeah you know vampirina
Garden Vincent Price well well they had
I grew up with what they call the Friday
Night Frights if you wanted to find a
horror movie on TV back in the like in
the 60s you have to go to Friday night
11 o'clock on a local station
which would have the temerity you know
the guts to run one and then you always
had some horrible tacky horror host
right and I mean really they did the
sets with no money Flats falling down
people who were looking but that's the
only way people would know to watch this
horror movie yeah but that but that's
when the idea spawned well that's like I
said well that's the difference if I was
Charlie Brewster I'd go to Peter Vincent
and when I had that I couldn't get home
fast enough to write I mean and I I
don't think I've ever had an exciting
experience like it because I was
literally falling on the floor and
screaming with laughter I really am
pounding my feet in my hands are saying
this is so funny I can't believe this
I'm almost Champions just it was
it was it was so
so ripe with pie it was so amusing ripe
with possibilities so much fun I don't
know what and what it turned out to be
is a love letter to horror fans
everywhere yeah and and I think what's
given the what's given Fright Night the
legs that it has is that
is that horror fans recognize themselves
in it